you got to start from a place put it
like this have you I I don't know if you
heard of this Green Deal where they want
to take 70% of anyone that makes over
ten million dollars seventy percent of
their income
that's hilarious it's the dumbest thing
that's a OC right yeah it's the dumbest
thing ever
I mean I wasn't calling her but no no no
I I like her to say good luck bitch as a
expression yes I like her too
I like your butt I'll agree with her
that but I like her but what I'm saying
is my friend was like oh you know if the
Democrats win that's gonna get passed
because we hate rich people and I go
that's the problem we're starting at
hate the reason why you think it's gonna
pass because you think people hate rich
people see and that's but you gotta have
a fix it here's nothing first of all
you've got incompetent use of funds like
where does the money go artax worse idea
that if you tax the rich that all sudden
all the problems will stop existing that
is so silly you still have incompetent
people that are distributing the money
they just create more jobs they'll be
more red tape and we get one more that's
yeah we got to do is figure out a real
plan for engineering our civilization
better that's that's what people have to
do and they should be like real
discussion from like real experts
biologists historians people who really
understand he was psychologists people
really understand human beings really
understand what's wrong with our society
today and we have an open discussion but
you know Beck uni that never out that
but that can never happen of course you
can but another right now because of the
government because they here's the thing
what do you mean that can happen we have
to look at it and try the priority but
no it goes by it goes by the whoever
parties in charge their priorities it's
not like my problem is to make it a
priority for the nation that's what I'm
saying but it's not impossible
but until you have a person I believe
everything to be fixed this is a simple
fix if you just elect a person that
takes some republican values and some
democratic values the thing is right now
in politics you have to be one or the
other like if I can if a person came in
as go you know what I like these
Republican ideas
I like these democratic ideas less roll
i'ma be down the middle and less roll
with Bob
a centrist exist yeah but it needs to
win but that can happen it can happen
all of it but in person look but until
that happens what does it mean though
does it
every four years we figure out what
happens right and before a trump won we
never thought a reality show fucking guy
could win but that guy won yeah and you
go okay well now we know that happens
all this stuff can happen this it's not
like we're not asking for alchemy we're
not trying to turn lead into gold we're
trying to figure out a way but you're
going against a system that then is is
you are no we there's a new system the
new system is the system of public
opinion which is readily accessible
absolutely and that's never happened
before there's never been a time where
everyone had a say in one way shape or
form whether it's through commenting
through Instagram or Twitter or social
media that's one of the reasons why
upholding the freedom of speech and
these things is so important even if
people are saying things you don't agree
with yeah the only way this all gets
sorted out is we get to figure out a way
to express ourselves and there's gonna
be arguments back and forth but what you
got to do is someone's got to put forth
an educated plan like a plan that's
based on science and reason and a plan
that you can debate against opposers of
that plan but when you have people that
don't believe in science a lot of how do
you how do you totally but surely you
have to get there it's gonna take
generation this is what I'm saying it's
like the momentum of our stubbornness
and our past and the the sort of the
systems that we find ourselves stuck in
systems behavior and thinking culture
all that stuff is gonna take a long time
yeah when we sort the wheat from the
chaff we got to figure out what's good
and what's bad and we're doing it we're
doing it but they were doing it actively
it's frustrating because you like
goddamnit
this is the worst time we still have all
these problems we still have cops
shooting people we still have crime
we still have Wall Street theft we still
have all this stuff yeah but you know
what I like them but you know what I
like is we know about it now yeah where
it's not hidden like 20 years ago
like you heard in let's go 30 years ago
you heard NWA make that song at the
police yeah and they're talking about
the same things that are happening today
except you would hear the song ago oh
that's a great song that's not Rodney
King yeah rowdy kick you watched him get
the fuck beat out of him
on TV and here's the thing about the
Rodney King thing that guy apparently
was like we've done a bunch of crazy
shit right he got in a car chase with
the cops he beat the fuck out of
somebody before that there was a lot
going on you just got to see the end of
it while this guy is was young what was
he on I don't know if he was he on a
drug and I think he was on PCP PCP
apparently makes you like superhuman
strong I had a buddy of mine who got his
finger bitten off while he's on PCP say
didn't even know bitten off by who a
street fight yeah it's like he didn't
even realize his feet cuz he was he was
on PCP
he didn't realize somebody bit his
finger off and he went - yeah he had his
toe removed and his toe put onto his
finger where his finger used to be was
it the thumb no it's his pinky fingers
up his trigger finger so on one of us
and he had it curved so he could always
throw right hooks so is when you'd shake
his hand he would give you like this
weird handshake where he would shake
your hand but there was always one
finger that wouldn't try to tickle the
middle it didn't move good yeah because
they it was really his toe that they
replaced his finger with a toe that must
have looked weird it was weird it was
real weird yeah but that's PC piece on
crazy people in Boston man he was a
boxing coach ah yeah I don't know ma'am
it's just we need to get to a better
place
yeah we're getting to a better place but
I think it's a long slow process I think
we are in there I mean there's people
that say you like hey to minimize the
suffering that people feel right now
isn't just and for you to say that is
outrageous and it's just a hallmark of
your delusional perspective that's not
true this is not denying the awful
things of the world the awful things of
the world exist but if you tried to look
at this as a mathematical equation if
you looked above you would say well
there's a lot of problems here there's a
lot of competing factors there's
environmental factors like what are they
doing in the world what are they doing
at the ocean what are they doing in the
air oh Jesus everything's warming up and
people are fighting over what's causing
it like they're not even paying tent
this is madness but look how much
College there is look how much
discussion there is litter movements are
moving and growing and people are even
when they're misinformed it's still
there's activity there's all this stuff
going on even when you know someone says
hey we're gonna tax everybody that makes
more than 10 million dollars seventy
percent like bitching taxes shit yeah
just stop stop stop stop stop just
because someone works really hard you
can't take all of it look stop people
from stealing money stop people for but
if you if people say well we want
equality of outcome okay as soon as we
get equality of effort talk to me yeah
this soon is weaker because some people
don't hustle
they just don't and I don't know why
maybe it's the way they were raised
maybe they have poor nutrition
maybe they hookworm I don't know what
the fuck it is but don't say that
everybody's supposed to hit the right
spot and everyone's gonna get to this
spot and then after that spot we're
gonna divvy up all the money so nobody
ever makes more than $100,000 a year in
the world's a better place bitch that
doesn't make the world better no that
makes lazy people happy yeah that some
fucking juggernaut like Mark Cuban or
one of these billionaire characters is
like hustling constantly and gathering
up massive resources yeah he's playing
the game of Monopoly but he's playing to
24 hours a day seven days a week
that's his option he can do that you
can't stop people from doing that well
you can stop them it's from doing in
just things with that money and wait
maybe you can do is like help someone
like lean towards a like a Bill Gates
type situation where he does so much
good and so much charitable work and
helps out so many people there you go
huh well maybe it's not a bad thing for
a guy like that to have all that money
because you don't have to think of him
as just mr. moneybags like maybe you
think of him as he does have access to
all this money but he's also this
incredible resource for hope and change
and and prosperity for some fun thing I
think like I think people wouldn't mind
giving money to something that they see
being built like if there's work into it
right people hate the idea of just
giving money and not seeing something
from it sure you know guilty people that
don't know what the fuck to do with yeah
they're just gonna find a use for it
because that's what bureaucracy is yeah
I don't know Joe we just I don't know
either but I do know that it's
fashionable to say it sucks it's
fashionable to say everything sucks well
it's it's easy to say that but like you
said but I really think it starts with
if the government is not on the same
page and they're always fighting you
can't you can't move forward did all
this great stuff you can't move forward
because it starts from the top Jo that's
true but it starts from the top what's
interesting is one of the things that's
cool about the government fighting is
you get to see that like even the
president can't do the things that he
wants yes he has to consult with people
and they have to agree on something and
it has to be reasonable they have to
present it to the American people and so
the people have to represent their
constituents and so you're seeing this
really fascinating thing because you've
never had a guy like Trump in office
before so you see him say he's gonna do
things and then you see the rest it
isn't going the fuck you are yeah the
fuck you are and then you watch this
stalemate you watch this this go down
and you watch these people being forced
to negotiate in the way Trump is forced
to talk about Nancy Pelosi because she
has so much power you know you know you
have to call her cut oh yeah let the car
a toll which like the fuck adding but he
has to pay the respect because he knows
now golf claps right in his face she's
like man I it's so fun to watch it's so
fun to watch right now